what's the difference between awakening
and realizing
or realization
you see many teachers won't make a
distinction
for me i do make a distinction
and
some do
but i'm not the only one who does
is that what you awakening first of all
there are different kind of awakening
you know if you read grejie for instance
his first awakening he says the terror
of the moment to realize i am asleep
i don't know who i am
most people aren't awakened that way yet
to know i don't know who the hell i am
what am i what's meaning in my life why
am i here
that's the first awakening
for grade the second awakening is to
know
to
what you are to erupt into consciousness
now you know i am
pure
spirit that is aware and conscious of
itself
now for me realization
means that has become
your true self it has become a constant
um it's constantly integrated
it's not just uh you know it you
walk up to it you know you know i
experienced it
what about wisdom
so you're curious about many things
because
you see
you know buddhists talk about wisdom and
certain ways
you know but i think of it more in a
western way wisdom
you know and if you're a buddhist who is
the me knowing what emptiness is
for them they call that wisdom if you
really know from an experience
what is empty what is the emptiness of
self what is the emptiness of everything
they call that wisdom
for me and wisdom is more practical
which is
as i know myself as i know
my true self or my spiritual nature or
might i call true nature usually
and
and i
um
not know what have integrated it
and then
how i live it how i live my life is
living from that place
and living from that place being able to
live in that place
in response to the work the world the
world situation i find myself in
so that my response to the situation i'm
in
comes
informed and expressing
what i have learned what i am now
and that becomes a spontaneous and
natural and very appropriate
way of dealing with the situation that
appropriate and full way of dealing with
situation is wisdom knowing how to deal
with life situation from the spiritual
perspective including spiritual
perspective without denying the material
perspective for me is to be wise
that's as you know that's how western
philosophy was the religion
what wise president why is it not just
you can be yourself is how you live in
the world
you have to live wisely
does that make sense for you let me see
if i'm understanding this so the second
awakening because you refer to number
one and number two the second awakening
is more about the perception of a
particular insight than realization is
the persistence of that insight
and then wisdom is the conformance
between one's action and that insight
or is in my office that's a good way of
saying get good security yes
but uh the only addition i would say is
not just insight
is being
that
discovery like i discover
that my nature is a pure presence
which is a sense of being sense of
existence
that does not exist in my body it's pure
existence
i am
you see like
i i am but the i am
is the
it is a palpable sense
of uh
powerful sense of
uh
consciousness conscious of its
own
being it's because consciousness is not
a function consciousness is a reality
consciousness is something that is
and when consciousness knows itself
awakes to itself as oh that is what i am
i am this kind of luminous
uh aware presence aware of myself and
can be aware of other things
that will be
the realization
see the way that i'm wondering about
this is akin to a tree with branches
that all come from the same root and
then when one says that consciousness
realizes itself well let's imagine that
you're an example of that i don't
imagine that i'm an example of that so
just because you have found that out
even though at least in this model we're
all part of the same route it seems
localized to you it doesn't seem to
spread outside of your teachings and
helping people so the way that i'm
visualizing it is like a branch and then
there's a loop on that branch and that
is what is occurring when you say
consciousness realizes itself rather
than when consciousness realizes itself
another way of thinking of that all
these branches just intertwined at once
but i and probably some of the people
who are listening just because you or
some of the other people have had
insights or have had these realizations
of consciousness
realizing itself it doesn't mean they
have like for example i don't think i've
had it so how does that comport is it
that it is a separate branch because i'm
trying to understand this with the other
teaching that we're all the same in some
manner and so how is it that if you have
an insight and it's i don't have that
insight automatically
most people don't have that insight and
don't have the capacity for that insight
and it's not easy to have that kind of
insight
it it has to do with some kind of
maturations of one's
conscious and one's being on
subjectivities and
development of
one's heart so that the heart has
developed to the point where there is
the natural
desire to know what i am
that becomes a force
that opens up things
and most people are
are more busy with survival and
their jobs and families you know they
don't have the opportunity to or
enhance even the interest to devote to
this kind of
exploration so it is a very specialized
thing in some sense that's why
all around the world people who realize
they're not that many the few
you know and
because but it is a potential for all of
us
because we all have the spiritual nature
as our nature we have to say all of us
have the same nature
and that's one thing when insight we we
learn
when i discover i remember you know
years ago
when i first discovered uh
experienced presence oh i am i am i know
what i am
and i then felt
connected to all human beings
i felt i am as this conscious presence
i'm connected with all human beings
because all human beings are
have the same
presence the same
inherent
uh truth to
them so that showed me potential for
everybody
everybody can experience it
at some point you know if they dedicate
themselves to it or they happen to be
somewhat open or mature who have had the
right influence in their life you know
many factors yeah
you're right that
you know
just because i say this is my experience
that's why that doesn't mean i'm
assuming others experiencing that way so
everyone does have the capacity or or
not everyone does
everybody has the potential
but not the capacity not necessarily the
capacity you know what's the difference
between those two
potential is
is what you are capacity is capacity of
perception capacity of subtle perception
and different kind of
perception different kind of way
different kind of consciousness that
than we know
most human beings are aware of
consciousness and i see and hear and
have emotions and sensation all of that
but all of those
you know perceptual
organs have their spiritual counterpart
which i call subtle counterpart there's
inner seeing there's inner sensing
there's inner feeling that is not lost
those are the outer expression of it
so one can
some of us have some of those subtle
things but we're not aware of them so we
don't employ them
but some it requires development and
that is what what i see the role
meditation
meditation helps in developing some of
those capacities
should everyone have these realizations
like if you had a magic wand and you can
wave it do you think it's for everyone
or do you think it's for certain people
at a certain time or perhaps not for a
particular person at any time the reason
behind this question is that
i'm sure you've seen this in some
spiritual teachers they think that
everyone should be enlightened awakened
and they may even use words like
like you've used with development though
i don't think you meant it in this way
but as if the enlightened is higher than
someone else which then implies a
looking down at people who aren't
enlightened
well i mean spiritual teaching all
they have a teaching to help people
to access
a realm of reality that they're usually
not
accessing
so obviously they think it's there's a
value in that
and
having that openness that's capacity for
subtle access
and
but
i wouldn't say that any teaching will
will say
everybody should
it's not matter should it's more like
it's possible or everybody everybody has
a possibility
when it will happen for somebody
it's something magical something sort of
uh like a destiny of sort
so
i
i think it would be great if more people
are like that
you know because that will sort of move
the human race in terms of becoming more
human because really
that's another point that's important
occurred which is the more we are in
touch with our spiritual dimension the
more human we are
you see people don't know that most
people know think i am human i i am
human because i have a body human body i
have a human emotion i can think or i'm
rational that makes me human
for the sufis for instance they say no
no that's not human yet
to be truly human you have to have two
hearts
which mean a heart that can converse
with the divine
that makes me human a human you see
for the sufis is the bridge between the
divine and the physical world
and if you're not that bridge yet you're
sort of on the way to being human but
you're not totally human yet
so uh many people
and it is not looked at as a
gradation or or
one is better than other it's more like
a natural process like evolution
you know evolution happens in different
ways and
different areas and
different different ways
so we all human being can evolve
you know we evolved physically and
mentally
we can evolve spiritually too
and it is
it's hard to tell where it's going to
happen like when my students you know
come to me i don't know which one is
really going to go deeper than the other
you know
sometimes surprised for some people
after a while they seem to be
they can't go deeper and suddenly
something happens and they're you know
they surprised me how wonderful they
seem to know themselves you know
how they
start to experience themselves in a way
that's about liberating
so i wish it for a human being because
it has less suffering in it it has
more the
enjoyment of discovering reality i mean
you know you're a scientist
you know scientists explore
true science
you're not exploring so i could develop
something to sell or for because i'm
you know
given a grant and i have the
the pure sciences like you you want to
discover because you enjoy the discovery
the exploration
so
when one is awakened
you the discovery becomes the way we
live our life
we're having discoveries all the time i
discover about what i am what is life
what is it how a thing can be done in a
way that makes it more real more total
and it's wonderful for the way to live
you see it brings in more dimensions to
exist to life so definitely i wish it
for people but i'm not think everybody
should i mean it's up to the people
themselves what happens inside them
i don't for because of that in my school
i don't go i'll try to get students
i don't
i don't try to convert anybody and
it's ridiculous for me to do that it's
more like
i just
hear and i make
something
a point in
showing that i'm here and that's what i
do
and who's interested will will come you
see
and they can learn
what i can teach
so and
so although i wish it for a human being
to be
more themselves
more complete for everybody for
everybody wishes forever making me it
would mean they'll be happier deeper
more fulfilled that's what it means
you see
but do i say that everybody should
well some people are just that's not
what's happening in their life
they're
busy getting married or having kids or
something like that who am i to say no
you should
come here focus then meditate first you
know
understanding this twin concept of we
should value this or sorry forget about
the [ __ ] this is more valuable this
approach of being enlightened or
realizing or awakening and so on and of
course and being wise is more valuable
but on the other hand we should not or
we don't want to talk about should and i
from my cursory examination of the more
eastern practices it's as if they have a
phobia they're afraid of saying should
they don't want to talk about should but
they can talk about value and i don't to
me those two are tied so can you help
disentangle them
no i think most path most spiritual path
they do have a shirt there's not they
don't say it other should but they say
they advise people yes you should you
know that'll be a good thing for you to
do
but
usually a
really wise
teacher
will see when they meet people who is it
who it is
their time to learn that who isn't
because it's it's has to do with timing
it has to do with circumstances
so uh
although it is
valuable but
the first thing has to come first people
have to establish a life that's the
hindu model as you know first you become
a householder you're married and then
you go and fight the teacher
that's how they've done that you see
and not all of them because go and find
the teachers